[Music]
you're listening to how to be a better
human I'm your host Chris Duffy of the
many strange things about being a
comedian one of the biggest is how being
paid works I can perform the exact same
jokes and get paid wildly different
amounts sometimes I go to a conference
and I tell my jokes and I get a very
lucrative check other times I tell those
same jokes at a bar and they give me two
free seltzers it's the wild west out
there when it comes to joke prices so
when I got my first TV writing job I was
really surprised to learn that I was now
part of a small but powerful Union
called The Writer's Guild of America all
of a sudden my work included things like
minimum weekly rates Health Care
contributions a potential pension down
the road and rules about how I could be
treated by my bosses it was honestly
shocking to me the contrast between how
much better I was treated all of a
sudden it was night and day and also
here's a funny little side note when I
moved to LA I talked to one of the labor
organizers at the union and he told me
that the zip code that I had moved into
has the densest concentration of
unionized comedians in the world so
there are people on all sides of me
having a similar Revelation right now
being in a union and seeing the power
and the benefits it's really changed how
I think about organizing and Community
power because the only reason that the
writer's Guild is strong is because the
members are willing to stand together
and risk losing out on money and work to
protect each other whether you are an
established TV writer who is already
well into their career or someone just
starting out like me so in today's
episode we're going to dive deep into
the history power and promise of Labor
organizing it's a topic that has been in
the news quite a bit lately but many
people still have kind of an outdated
idea of what a union is and while
garment steel and Auto Workers they
still have powerful labor organizations
these days labor also includes education
and health care as well as Baristas Tech
workers and yes even comedy writers like
me but even if your job is not related
to a union you can still learn how to
use Collective power in our own lives
how to help us understand the common
struggle for rights and protections for
us all today's guest is Stanford
political science Professor Margaret
Levy here's a clip from her TED Talk
Martin Luther King exhorted us
to enrap ourselves in a single Garment
of Destiny
I have observed several unions that I've
studied built expanded and inclusive
communities of Fate In which large
numbers of others recognize that their
Destinies are entwined
despite differences and distances
this doesn't always happen
but it can and it must
we need as employees and citizens to
build solidarity through communities of
faith that crosses geographies and
differences but to do that we need to
re-imagine labor unions for now
after this quick break we're going to
reimagine what the new age of worker
solidarity looks like so do not go
anywhere you don't want to miss that
[Music]
okay welcome back on today's episode we
are talking labor unions and the power
of collective organizing hi I'm Margaret
Levy and I'm professor of political
science and Senior fellow at the center
for democracy development and rule of
law at Stanford University you know I
obviously I want to talk to you
specifically about unions but I'm also
interested more broadly in how you
started getting interested in inequality
and solutions to inequality so it really
goes back to the 1950s when I was a
small child and my mother took my
younger sister and I by the hand and we
marched in civil rights marches in
Baltimore Maryland where the
inequalities were clear and rampant
racially
divided but also the divisions based on
religion on nationality on class
so early on and that was partially my
father's influence as well I became very
interested in class and the divisions
that that perpetrated
and that led ultimately to an interest
in labor unions how have
labor movements or organizing played a
role in your own life I have not
actually been a member of the Union
because the the two places where I have
been a faculty member unionization has
not been has not occurred successfully I
did try to organize a labor union when I
was a teaching fellow as a graduate
student we failed but boy we tried can I
ask a question about that because I
think that sometimes it's really
presented as this kind of binary you win
or you lose but do you feel like you
gained something from the attempt to
organize you oh my God yes absolutely
you know I'm a political scientist I
study Collective action problems I study
power
and boy did I learn a lot about how
difficult Collective action is in part
because of the variety of ways in which
power can be exercised and some of them
are not with a heavy Club but with a
carrot what did you get out of that
though like I mean other than the sense
of like how hard it can be what were the
victories that you feel like you took
away from even a failed attempt at
organizing there was a personal benefit
of feeling much better about myself I
mean I've done the right thing I tried
hard
I'm the kind of person who loves to
learn so just that the learning
experience about power and about its
variety of forms
enhanced my own work and research this
is also my own bias but I feel like we
undervalued the importance of just that
feeling of solidarity of like listen
we're all on the same side even if it
doesn't end the fact that I have people
who have my back yeah yeah so it's the
solidarity which is a remarkable feeling
and I felt that in those civil rights
marches and in other things that I've
done since I and I have been in other
failed movements like the anti-war
movement but still that feeling of
solidarity is amazing but the other
feeling that's also incredibly important
is the feeling of self-respect the
feeling of dignity that you get from
engaging in an action because you know
it's right and because you know it will
help not just you
if it does help you but will help other
people as well other people who may not
for a variety of reasons they have
families they can't lose their jobs they
can't do something they may be
immigrants who are undocumented they
can't engage in particular actions and
put themselves at risk in that way so
there's a feeling of rightness and
goodness and self-empowerment by acting
on behalf of others that I think should
not be
should not be underplayed for those of
us who aren't as well versed in the
history of labor unions where did
labored unions really come from the
start of the labor movement goes way way
back depending on how you count it but
if we think about the Contemporary labor
movement it actually probably begins
with the Navy and various kinds of
mutinies that occurred in the Navy
including in in relatively contemporary
times early 19th century but the
industrial unions is and the craft
unions are really the beginning of the
kind of unionization that I study the
craft unions had their origins in the
medieval guilds they developed uniquely
in the 19th century
in various countries U.S Germany Britain
countries that were industrializing and
they organized first and a way to train
people to do the craft and to limit uh
access to that particular occupation as
a way both to ensure that the quality
was high but also to ensure that the pay
was high and that the working conditions
were reasonable so that was a first kind
of form of modern industrial
unionization where the craft unions
which ranged from cigar makers to
construction workers to when electricity
came in Electrical Workers The Long
Shore workers or the Dock Workers who I
have studied extensively were originally
a craft unions the next stage was the
Industrial unions or what we call the
industrial unions which really organized
all of the workers in a particular
industry so all of the automobile
workers all of the steel workers no
matter what their particular skill or
craft in the factory setting was and
that was a very important form of
unionization and those were very large
scale and therefore extremely it led to
some of the most militant actions that
we think about in the history of
unionization the big steel strikes in
Pittsburgh in the turn of the century
period and multiple big strikes that
occurred the sit-down strikes in the
1930s in the automobile industry for
example there's so much history here and
we could do a whole podcast just on the
the history but one of the things that I
feel like comes up in maybe the pop
culture understanding of unions
especially recently is I I hear a lot of
people saying like if you like the
weekend Bank unions you know if you like
working nine to five having those be
your set hours think unions those kind
of I think are the some of the real
benefits that unions fought for that
regular people have latched on to are
those representative of the kind of
Victories that you unions have made are
those kind of outliers in a broader
struggle they're very much part of the
labor movement that is the kind of goal
that unions had and it wasn't just for
the members it was for most many unions
many of the unions particularly the
industrial unions were thinking about
societal issues they were politicized
unions who were trying to they helped
win a social security they helped win us
Health Care yes they did give us the
weekend because they worked hard for a
working week that had
a period of rest attached to it so if
unions are are so good for workers why
is it that union membership has been in
Decline well unions come with two
disadvantages that have hurt them a lot
I'll start with the ones that the unions
create so what unions create for
themselves has often been high dues that
corrupt leadership may take advantage of
if there is corrupt leadership so there
have been unions which have been very
problematic there have been unions which
have been too bureaucratic that have
been corrupt there have been racist
unions as well as unions that have been
committed to racial solidarity in which
I include the Longshore workers and I
include the teamsters which have had a
long history of commitment uh cross
they'll organize anything that moves so
they don't care what color that person
is so they've been very committed to
that but some unions have not been you
look at the history of the during the
war in Vietnam in the U.S the unions and
the left came into conflict after being
in solidarity for so long so there were
all kinds of things that the unions did
that made them unpopular with some of
their members and with much of the
public but the biggest problem for
unions is the kind of campaigns that
have been waged against unions by
government and by corporations not all
governments are anti-union but an awful
lot of governments have been in the
history particularly of the U.S if you
look at Union rates in other countries
you'll see even in countries like
Britain and Australia which have very
similar kinds of constitutional
arrangements and legal Arrangements that
we do the union rate is is much higher
in places like Sweden it's very very
high the legal structure in the U.S has
been very unfriendly to unions the
National Labor Relations Act which was
not superb but it was good and better
and so much an improvement over what was
preceded it that that's of almost 100
years old now we have not updated our
laws in accordance with changes in the
union we now have unions trying to
organize and organized in the service
sector and the gig sector in all kinds
of sectors which aren't covered
by the National Labor Relations Act so
the laws have been against unions but
the corporations and some governments
have exercised extraordinary campaigns
and put lots of money into fighting
unions and creating bad PR for unions
and making it hard for unions engaging
often in illegal practices but it's hard
because of the bureaucratic Machinery to
adjust those things to stop them from
engaging in those practices I certainly
feel like in my lifetime the
public
perception of unionization and of the
labor movement in general has changed
quite a lot I think in the last couple
years it seems like there's a lot more
understanding of what a union does a lot
more energy at least in my world of
people thinking about what a just
workplace would look like and thinking
about how to achieve that I wonder is
that just attributable to like the
pandemic and forcing us all to look at
Society in a big different way or or is
it a force that's existed before the
pandemic as well I think it existed
before the pandemic it has certainly
been Amplified by the pandemic if
anything and brought the Public's
attention to a whole set of workers that
they weren't paying any attention to
before those we are now calling
essential workers the irony of how we
for a short period of time called them
essential and then have so rapidly
seemed to decide that actually they're
not essential if it means we have to
treat them as essential I think that has
been a real radicalizing Force for a lot
of people myself included I think that's
right so that's why I said the pandemic
Amplified that that feeling so I think
there was already a recognition that
something had to change in the power
relations between the employers and the
employees whoever the employers were
defined as because in the gig economy as
we know that becomes a very complicated
problem but certainly that there was a
power relationship that needed to be
corrected and improvements in the
quality of work life and work
compensation
so that preceded the pandemic and there
were already groups that were trying to
rethink including the labor movement the
traditional union movement itself trying
to rethink its strategies of organizing
remember there were attempts to reform
labor law under Obama which preceded the
pandemic I mean all kinds of service
employees health care employees have
organized in ways that were not and
that's some of that's been relatively
recent some of the the home care workers
or mobilization has been relatively
recent and quite large scale in terms of
numbers a phrase that I've heard you use
in talks and that I know you've used in
a bunch of your books is communities of
fate so not Faith but f-a-t-e can you
explain to me why you find that to be a
really crucial phrase when we're talking
about these types of actions and
movements absolutely so in a book that I
wrote with John Alquist called in the
interest of others which really looks at
a series of unions that may be in some
ways exceptional but also prove the
possibility of this kind of organization
what we discovered was that the unions
that were able to mobilize their members
beyond their narrow economic
self-interest which is after all what
unions are designed to meet those that
were successful in doing so constructed
what we called it and now call an
expanded Community an inclusive
community of faith not just a community
of Fate but an expanded and inclusive
community of Fate that really made
people feel that their Destiny was
linked to those often distant others who
could would never reciprocate
they felt like if it could happen to
them it could happen to us we have to
act now in order to prevent those kinds
of abuses of human rights of well-being
from continuing
we're going to take a quick break and we
will be right back with more from
Margaret about the struggles and
limitations of organizing what does
solidarity look like when things do not
go according to plan when things start
going wrong we're gonna find out right
after this
[Music]
and we are back union rates have been in
serious Decline and at the same time an
MIT survey revealed that 50 of the
non-union Workforce would join a union
if they were given the chance so why is
that where's the mismatch coming from
here's another clip from Margaret's TED
Talk
big read about the Amazon warehouse
failed to win a union representation
election in Alabama
they failed because of concerted
employer opposition
indeed there are many employers
and politicians
who are preventing the reform of labor
laws passed nearly a century ago in
another era and another economy
so Margaret on this show we're always
trying to think about like how do you as
a regular person how do you take these
big ideas and these amazing theories and
actually put them into practice and I
think that something that is very
powerful to me about unions is it can so
often feel
like the only way that these things
could change if is if I was the person
who owned the company is if somehow I
was the boss then I could make things
fair then people could be treated well
but what can I do as just a regular
person who's working here right I have
no power I sometimes do work as a
television writer and when I do
television writing work I am in the
writer's Guild of America and so right
instantly I don't have to fight for it
I'm instantly in the union and I find
that I'm treated very differently in
that work because there's a big Union
that's quite powerful and so there's set
rates and there's set protections and
then when I go do something like stand
up or like host a podcast I'm kind of on
my own so for someone who isn't already
working in an area that's been really
heavily unionized which is most people
how do you start to kind of Build That
Power when it feels like well if I say
no they'll just fire me and I can't
afford to get fired I mean this has
always confronted people who are trying
to unionize right you know the the big
moment in the sit-down strikes in the
Ford plants in the General Motors plants
in the Detroit area in the 1930s was
when the Secretary of Labor Francis
Perkins and the governor of Michigan
decided not to not to call in the
National Guard to put down the strike
but rather to tell the National Guard to
stand on the side and and to intervene
if there was actual violence including
by the corporation
that was a big sea change I mean so
imagine if you were in a world which we
are a bit in but not as much as then
where not only did you have to worry
about how you were going to actually
mobilize others and convince them to be
part of it but where you had the huge
Machinery of government and the
corporate's private armies arrayed
against you now luckily there are now
organizations that are there to help
most of them are available
by going on the web they're things like
unit that tell you how to organize get
tell you the rules of the game will give
you advice so there are organizations
out there that can help including the
traditional labor movement the AFL-CIO
still provides assistance to those who
are trying to organize those resources
are in fact available and they're
available in other parts of the world as
well what advice do you have for someone
who is fighting against that mindset of
well this is bad and unfair and maybe
even exploitative but
if I don't do this work
they're going to find someone else and I
need this job
It's Tricky that is tricky always tricky
and that's where these organizations can
help you know and publicity can help so
if we look at the the cases of the
Amazon warehouse workers for example or
some of the Starbucks people and the
kind of Retribution that they have been
receiving it's now being somewhat
rectified in part because of the
publicity
that so Howard Schultz had to change the
processes and policies he was using
where the stores that were unionizing
weren't going to be treated worse than
the stores that were the workers weren't
going to be treated worse than the ones
who weren't it's a campaign and it's an
effort and there will be no question
about it some people will end up losing
they'll be the martyrs to the cause but
the idea is to try to in prevent that
martyrdom as much as possible to provide
an environment of support in terms of
mobilization of publics who can be
supportive as well as using the laws and
finding lawyers who will help to protect
those who choose to organize it is a
right it is in fact allowed to organize
are there things that are very exciting
for you when you think about the future
of
organizing and labor movements I think
the most exciting organizing things that
are going on are less about Labor and
more around the environment I mean I am
just
in awestruck with what young people have
been doing in terms of mobilizing other
young people in all kinds of efforts to
bring public awareness to how important
the environmental question is and I
think the unions could learn a lot from
those environmental activists in terms
of really speaking to where people are
and addressing the kinds of questions
that you're raising so I think there's a
learning that could go the other way as
well from and often social movements do
learn from each other the labor movement
helped the Civil Rights Movement the
Civil Rights Movement taught the women's
movement you know we learn from each
other in social movement world I love
that I think that's so crucial and
important and you know we've talked a
little bit about how you can
get attention and publicity and how that
can change things and how you know
strikes are one way but also visibility
and even just having an action that that
draws attention can be another way of
changing forces and changing situations
do you think that things have really
changed now that so many more people
have access to media in the sense that
like you can post a story online and
everyone can see it it doesn't have to
go through a newspaper or through some
sort of powerful person is has that
changed organizing for better or has
that also made it more complicated
because it can be buried by
misinformation so how did you get
information about unions in the past
particularly when distances felt long
and media was not so rapid you look at
the stories that were written up in the
traditional newspapers and which I've
done at various times and they had no
relationship to what's actually going on
from the perspective that I know as
someone who's looked at The Archives and
the history people are changed The
Narrative all the time so what one needs
to do in this case as in any organizing
case is to capture the narrative and to
create a narrative that appeals to lots
of people and that in some ways
overwhelms The Narrative that is based
on misinformation or on anti-union
biases or whatever it is I'll come back
to the Amazon workers and the Starbucks
workers because they're some of the most
recent and they're in the news these
days
they have really been capturing the
narrative and that's been critical so
they have really changed the view of
what these unions are trying to do who
they represent who the people are
they're not allowing the corporations to
tell the story
um it seems like one of the things that
I'm taking away from our conversation is
that so many of the things that I
believed about the labor movement or
about unions are either half truths or
outright not accurate and that there's
so much of the history that is directly
relevant to the situations that are
arising today and that I really need to
educate myself more about like where
things have been so that I can see where
things could go and how we can push them
in the right direction how can we see
what are the the most useful moments in
history to look at for the future now or
where we are in this current moment
there are so many great books on labor
history in in the U.S you know Nelson
lichtenstein's state of the unions I'll
give a call out to that it's a terrific
book it's not up to the very moment but
it gives you a sense of the important
moments in the history of the American
labor movement and there are a number of
equally good books but the real issue is
how do we draw from labor history when
do we draw from labor history when is it
relevant and I think it's relevant in
the following sense one it's important
for people to recognize
what unions have done and what their
absence does
so the fact that unions were once so
strong relatively meant that certain
kinds of legislation got passed no not
to everybody's taste I mean the the New
Deal legislation is something that
there's a whole movement against and we
have governments that represent I mean
presidents that represent that from
Ronald Reagan on maybe even Nixon on so
you know that's part of the history is
that the unions gave us a lot
uh but they also gave us a controversial
lot things that there's at least part of
the American public is very resistant to
cease in a way that is problematic that
the state is providing things that
shouldn't or government is providing
things that shouldn't be providing it
also comes out of a collectivist
tradition which you seem to be
celebrating and I certainly do which is
the idea that we are a large and
expanded and inclusive community of
faith in the best of all possible worlds
and that we do have to act together and
in solidarity to make things happen but
America is grounded in a very
individualist tradition as well which
sees these kinds of things which bring
us into solidarity as problematic
because they may in some ways abridge
our individual Freedom our individual
liberty particularly when they get
institutionalized into a union so both
of those things are part of the history
part of the history is what the unions
have accomplished part of the history is
who resisted the unions and why part of
the history is what happens when the
unions Decline and what we lose with
that decline which is a whole lot of
social protections and part of the
history is who prefers that way of
having the society organized what are
the experiments what are new forms of
unionization that that are developing
now so what's happening in the
warehouses and in places like Starbucks
and in the economy is a whole different
kind of organizing that's going on
different ways and different strategies
of organizing different ways of creating
PR around what's happening different
ways of mobilizing resources for those
who are attempting to form labor
organizations of different kinds and
create worker voice and worker power
so I think there are lots of experiments
going on and some of them are beginning
to be quite successful as we've seen
some
aren't so successful and that's you look
at the history of unions and that's
always the case the history of anything
the history of government you know you
try things
they fail they succeed they partially
succeed they have to be tweaked and
that's what's happening right now and I
think we have to you know one of the
things that's also happening is
rethinking what teachers unions look
like what police unions look like what
hospital workers unions look like so
that they really are something that are
serving not just those who are working
there but also and not but but the
general public and those particular
kinds of consumers who need to use their
services I I just want to add and
acknowledge my own bias here because
definitely the idea of unionization is
one of the topics that I've changed my
mind about the most in my adult life
one of my first jobs was teaching at a
public charter school that was not
unionized and at the time I felt like
that was a non-issue right I was pretty
bought into the idea that the teachers
union was a union that was protecting
the worst employees from being fired I
felt like as an organization they do not
have students best interests at heart
that was what I felt at the time and so
I would say my opinion was like mostly
neutral to negative
but then the more that I learned about
the history of unions the more that I
saw what actually happens in the
workplace as a whole not just on my
little individual School the more that I
started to really see the importance of
a union and now I've kind of come all
the way around to working in the
entertainment industry and being
actively involved in a strong powerful
Union
and it I guess it seems like many people
have a somewhat similar experience to
that where they work and as they work
they're won over by the idea of
unionization as they see the difficulty
of holding any sort of line on Norms or
pay or workplace standards alone as an
individual how hard it is to make any
sort of change just as one person
so
I'm curious one to get your reaction to
that and two to know whether you think
the best case scenario would be a world
where everyone is unionized like do you
want to see a hundred percent
unionization or does that not really
make sense I don't think it makes sense
to be 100 unionization I do think what
makes sense is to be a hundred percent
covered by rules and regulations
enforced by law
that ensure that your work is
compensated that you travel if you're
forced to travel you are traveling under
certain conditions I think you know the
unions in some of those some of the
stuff that you were describing unions
are second best to a set of laws and
rules and a state of the world that
takes those things for granted for every
person who enters the workforce right
and the unions have been critical to
that because they are a power base to
make that happen so it's not just about
your individual workplace it's about
ensuring that those rules get put in
place for everybody one of the things we
haven't discussed
is how the diversity of the labor force
has changed when I talk about the
industrial unions of the 1930s it's
mostly white men right
it's now black and white men it's now
women it's now people of multiple
backgrounds and with multiple skills and
capacities we have all kinds of ways of
predicting that diversity that are in
law and all kinds of ways that we don't
as we're seeing in the current legal
regime so part of my advocacy of unions
part of why I would like to see a higher
percentage of people in unions is for
its political power
which will translate into economic
changes but we need that political power
to actually persuade those who in
principle are representing us
to take our interest to Heart
and to ensure that our workers which
includes almost all of us but not a
hundred percent
are in fact given the kind of treatment
we deserve as contributing members of
this society and final question for you
what is something that has helped you to
be a better human whether it is a book
an idea a movie a piece of music a
person could be anything what's one
thing that's helped you to be a better
human
I actually think here I will turn to the
labor movement being the Harry Bridges
chair of Labor studies which I had the
honor to be at the University of
Washington brought me into close contact
with the ilw the international Longshore
and Warehouse Union what a remarkable
set of people
remarkable set of people they were the
ones who taught me what it really means
to build a community of fate and one
that is inclusive and encompassing they
just thinking about them brings tears to
my eyes
they put their money where their mouth
was or their mouths where their money
was both things they really um they
developed beliefs about how important it
was to act in the interest of others and
they acted on those beliefs
thank you so much Margaret it has been
such a pleasure to talk to you I really
appreciate you making the time to be on
the show thank you Chris my pleasure
that is our show for today thank you so
much for listening to how to be a better
human I am your host Chris Duffy and a
very big thank you to today's guest
Margaret Levy she has written a bunch of
fantastic books and given a ton of
in-depth talks about the issues that we
touched on today so you can find a lot
more from her online from Ted our show
is brought to you by Jimmy Gutierrez
Anna philan rithu jagannath Erica Yoon
and Julia Dickerson who care about each
other's entwined Fates from transmitter
media were brought to you by Greta Cohen
and fair degrash who act in the interest
of others and from PRX Jocelyn Gonzalez
and Sandra Lopez monsalve with whom I
truly feel solidarity thanks most of all
to you for listening to our show please
if you like this episode share with a
friend share with a co-worker send it to
your whole workplace and leave us a
positive rating or review to help us
spread the word we will be back with
more episodes for you next week until
then take care
[Music]